[Music]
okay everybody so I am privileged and
honored today to talk to living
legendary actor Jackson Robert Scott
Jackson how are you thank you I'm doing
good I wouldn't call myself legendary
but thank you so much for saying that
I'm doing good today yeah yeah no I mean
look even if I'm exaggerating a little
bit you're gonna get there you're on the
path you are a master at your craft at
such a young age it's really just a joy
to watch you and I believe now yeah oh
no problem and with you playing Bodhi in
lock and key
did you absolutely nail it as this
character and I'm just curious did you
read the graphic novel to prepare for it
or after the show or did you just kind
of take it from the script well there
was actually an original pilot that was
going to be on Hulu and during that time
I read the first welcome to Lovecraft
one an airport and I thought it was
really cool and then of course the pilot
got picked up by Netflix which was
really cool and basically that's how we
got to Netflix and the whole cast of the
original pilot was recasted everyone
except me which I thought was pretty
cool thank you
yeah and then I stayed on for the first
season of watching TV on Netflix so yeah
that was pretty awesome yeah that's a
great story right there even and I mean
you having this experience already
through being in huge movies like it and
you take on these lead roles I thought
what was really interesting about your
character here in locking keys that you
know when Kinzie and Tyler are having
all this drama at the school I always
felt like Bodie was like taking care of
real business in the house you know yeah
well you guys are having drama I'm here
fun magical kids that basic
help us unlock unlock he's in tune away
because all these keys
there wouldn't be add there wouldn't be
a season one without the keys and there
100% wouldn't be a season 2 without all
the kids as well cuz they're there the
things that bring to show the life shame
which I really think is cool ok
totally and with Bodie putting her in a
hole all the hard work finding these
keys watching you on screen you see
you're running around this key house
constantly like like a madman like I
always wonder you like a serious workout
doing this are you like exhausted from
running so much I'm hunter you can call
me and now I I'm now called a key hunter
that is now my job around he house so if
you had to pick one key in real life for
Jackson what key would you pick anywhere
key a hundred percent I just love the
fact that you can go anywhere at any
time or any door you've seen it
basically like what I'm saying is you
could go all the way let's say to China
and you unlock the door and you go to
China you're at the Great Wall of China
and it's really cool you're like okay
now I want to go to the beach so now you
go to Playa del Carmen Mexico and you
because you look up maybe at your phone
or on the television you're like okay
but let's look up like a resort and then
there's there's a door and you're like
oh okay I'll just go there you think you
can go wherever you want to at any time
see that's an amazing cell and a pitch
there to Jesse because I was always a
head key person myself but man you've
convinced me for the anywhere key and it
seems like you have such a great
imagination too which is awesome and
that you understand these keys really
well and I was wondering - there's so
much magical stuff oh my god yes right
you're pro like I said Legend and what
was your favorite scene to film in this
season of lock and key I'm definitely
thinking on the part where I'm going
through the house
or or it's a tie between the wheelies
and where I'm in in my actual head which
I thought was really cool yeah that was
that was awesome did you laughs it was
really cool inside when I when I got to
go inside like from the outside it just
looks like a grey box once you went in
there was all this music and there's
this if I can it was basically a mini
arcade and in this studio and I'm like
wow that is pretty pretty cool yeah I
just wanted to play the whole time I
didn't I didn't at that point I just
wanted to play the games in there and no
and yeah I was just amazed at what at
what they created
so speaking of games it sounds like you
went to that stuff so like is there do
you play video games in your downtime or
like mobile games is there anything like
you're into right now yeah I just
finished Pokemon shield yeah those are
pretty good games I'm trying to find new
games for me to play because I finished
Pokemon silom shield on my old time
because I play on switch oh come and
yeah yeah in my all-time favorite game
just because of the story it would
definitely have to be Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild but my favorite story
for no game I really really really draw
the graphics are amazing just had a good
storyline that's great I'm happy you
value that in a game cuz I'm definitely
with you on that because even for me
growing up I loved the original Zelda 64
which is a yeah right now we are kind of
time out if you've played it but yes
yeah so what's wild about this Jackson
is that I'm a big collector of these
Funko pops and I actually have the
Georgie pop from it in front of me and
I'm wondering yeah so I want to know how
do you take in seeing yourself in like
action figures and on shirts like what
is that like action figure I think is
honestly pretty cool honored
t-shirt I think that's pretty cool as
well it's just I don't really know how
to how to express I feel I I think it's
pretty cool but that's all I could say I
mean it's not like I'm absolutely
surprised or I'm absolutely not okay
it's cool I love that yeah I think it's
really cool to be yeah Funko pop I know
you're crushing no you're doing awesome
and now I just want to just shift gears
for one second just talk a little bit
about it if you don't mind I yeah I want
to know cuz you know you know people
have asked you this a billion times
about being on set with penny wise and
you're in front of this like the most
terrifying clown ever are you now like a
pro or like do you even have a fear of
clowns anymore have you seen it all like
are you just numb to that I've honestly
never had a fear of clowns at all and
even when I was filming it cuz I
honestly at the time I didn't even know
what the concept of it was and I was
just like cool I'm here to film I mean
but you gotta look at reality versus
fiction you know so my parents told me
reality and fiction and they told me I
take it very well and I know I I think
it sounds like they're right man you are
you are a very smart young man dude like
I'm very impressed right now I feel like
I'm talking to someone who's been acting
for like centuries like it's pretty
crazy oh you're welcome
now did you have do you currently have
any actors or actresses you kind of look
up to right now is there like someone
that kind of inspires you one of my
favorite actors is definitely count
100% what a pic yeah I I've just I did I
like I want I love the matrix a lot and
I also like John wick and the new
spongebob movie I thought it was pretty
cool that he got like a cameo a
tumbleweed or maybe he has a bigger part
so he's like you know obviously an
action icon so you kind of right now fit
the mold of like you are like already
and like this horror actor legendary
category so like do you ever see
yourself
oh no problem but do you see yourself
like ever like oh I want to try action
soon or I want to do comedy like where
does your head turn it oh yeah yeah all
the time
I I really I'm not really I hope that
directors and producers don't just
stereotype me as um as like a horror
actor because it's not just towards that
I like to do like walking to you I guess
you could say done sort of sort of the
comedy relief in it and I honestly like
comedies a lot in actions
I really think those are my type of
movies even though I do do a whole I do
horrors I do act in words um I think
they're pretty cool except I just you
know I'd rather be in something that I
can watch okay totally I mean yeah and
like you have that range you've already
shown that and you're versatile so
that's exciting to see where you're like
career will go and what you do and like
you know maybe you'll be a superhero one
day just like never know it's like I'm
in an action movie or a or a comedy
movie um is just I all my friends have
not been able to see it my my projects
until walking to you and you will not
believe how many like even just today
today at school when I was going from
band and all the sixth graders
the fifth graders were in the band room
at once all they would say to me is
Aloha and I I do not get enough of it I
do not get enough of it man your job I
did I know I let me say that again and I
got too much of it that's what I'm not
and I did not I got the opposite of
getting enough of it
Wow yes he like you're already getting
ready for the paparazzi the TMZ life
like you you're learning this I mean
yeah yeah oh I think them you know
because that means they're supporting me
you know it's it they're not just saying
that because it's it's funny and it is
but they're also doing that because
you're supporting me like my whole
school supports me which i think is
really nice Avantika do that in
supporting my acting because a lot of
times it does take time out of school
and and they can and they understand
that and we tell them that we haven't we
have a tutor um usually at the studio or
wherever a little filming where I can do
my school work away from school which i
think is also really cool that I can do
two things at once you know enjoying
what I like to do and doing my regular
everyday child stuff I guess yeah I mean
you're you're a hustler here man and
like you you're also humble you're
throwing it all at me I'm ready for it
you know this is big no but um just
wrapping this up I want to know to like
do you ever have dreams of like wanting
to go behind the camera and write or
direct one day I think that would be
pretty I think that would be pretty cool
but um I just I like acting right now
and I would like to do that but I just I
I just really like acting and honestly
compared to directing and writing acting
will always be in my number one spot and
that whole genre just because it needed
to make the movie a lot
No yeah hell yeah and yeah you're the
face no I think that you nailed that and
the last question I actually want to ask
you is is there any shows or movies
you've recently been watching that you
can recommend to your fans that you're
kind of into or like a movie you saw
recently that yeah get that season 2 so
yeah and look before I let Jackson go if
you're listening to this like he said
watch lock and key it's on Netflix
everyone has Netflix put it on you have
no excuse you can also watch and play
Georgie and it chapter one and two and
he also stars across from Taylor showing
in The Prodigy another horror movie yeah
so if you want to see Jackson Roberts
Acula in multiple ways and that includes
just being funny serious
although literally killer in prodigy
yeah exactly
Jackson I was gonna say Aloha to you but
now I can't because I see that you're
sick of it from your schoolmates so I'm
not gonna know hey Jackson I think I
think I yes say it no no I'm not gonna
say you say aloha to me
so you feel No
Aloha Jackson
[Music]